but most civilized people are out of
touch with reality because
they confuse the world
as it is
with the world as they think about it
and talk about it and describe it
for on the one hand there is the real
world and on the other a whole system of
symbols about that world which we have
in our minds
these are very very useful symbols all
civilization depends on them
but like all good things they have their
disadvantages
and the principal disadvantage of
symbols is that we confuse them with
reality
just as we confuse money
with actual wealth
and our names
about ourselves our ideas of ourselves
our images of ourselves with ourselves
now of course reality
from a philosopher's point of view is a
dangerous word
a philosopher will ask me what do I mean
by reality
am I talking about
the physical world of nature
or am I talking about a spiritual world
or what
and to that I have a very simple answer
when we talk about the material world
that is actually a philosophical concept
so in the same way if I say that reality
is spiritual that's also a philosophical
concept and reality itself is not a
concept reality is
and we won't give it a name
now it's amazing what doesn't exist in
the real world
for example in the real world there
aren't any things
nor are there any events
that doesn't mean to say that the real
world is a perfectly featureless blank
it means that it is a marvelous system
of Wiggles
in which we describe things and events
in the same way as we would project
images on a raw shark plot
or pick out
particular groups of stars in the sky
and call them constellations as if they
were separate groups of stars well there
are groups of stars in The Mind's Eye in
our system of Concepts
they are not
out there as constellations already
grouped in the sky
so in the same way the difference
between myself
and all the rest of the universe is
nothing more than an idea
it is not a real difference
and meditation is the way in which we
come to feel
our basic inseparability
from the whole universe
and what that requires is
that we
shut up
that is to say that we become interiorly
silent
and cease from the interminable chatter
that goes on inside our skulls because
you see most of us think compulsively
all the time that is to say we talk to
ourselves
I remember when I was a boy
we had a common saying talking to
yourself is the first sign of Madness
now obviously
if I talk all the time
I don't hear what anyone else has to say
and so in exactly the same way if I
think all the time that is to say if I
talk to myself all the time I don't have
anything to think about except thoughts
and therefore I'm living entirely in the
world of symbols
and I'm never in relationship with
reality
all right now that's the first
basic reason for meditation but there is
another sense and this is going to be a
little bit more difficult to understand
why we could say that meditation doesn't
have a reason
or doesn't have a purpose and in this
respect it's unlike almost all other
things that we do except perhaps making
music and dancing
because when we make music
we don't do it
in order to reach a certain point such
as the end of the composition
if that were the purpose of music to get
to the end of the piece then obviously
the fastest players would be the best
and so likewise when we are dancing we
are not aiming to arrive at a particular
place on the floor as we would be if we
were taking a journey
when we dance
the journey itself
is the point
when we play music The playing itself is
the point
and exactly the same thing is true in
meditation
meditation is the Discovery
that the point of life is always arrived
at in the immediate moment
and therefore if you meditate
for an ulterior motive that is to say to
improve your mind to improve your
character to be more efficient in life
you've got your eye on the future and
you are not meditating
because the future
is a concept
it doesn't exist
as the proverb says tomorrow never comes
there is no such thing as tomorrow there
never will be
because time is always now
and that's one of the things we discover
when we stop talking to ourselves and
stop thinking we find there is only a
present only an eternal now
so
it's funny then isn't it that one
meditates for no reason at all
except we could say for the enjoyment of
it and here I would interpose the
essential
principle that meditation is supposed to
be fun
it's not something you do as a grim
Beauty
the trouble with religion as we know it
is that it is so mixed up with grim
duties
we do it because it's good for you it's
a kind of self-punishment
well meditation when correctly done has
nothing to do with all that
it's a kind of digging the present it's
a kind of grooving with the Eternal now
and
brings us into a state of peace
where we can understand
that the point of life
a place where it's at
is simply Here and Now
[Music]